[Music]
not all heroes wear capes some of them
wear pokemon t-shirts and a baseball cap
you might think you've heard of every
superhero out there with marvel and dc
dominating the box office and the
incredible cactus man fighting crime on
the mean streets of edinburgh
but there is one tiny aspiring hero
you'd likely never heard of in a world
filled with danger and evildoers one
young boy armed with a pure heart and
some telekinetic powers dared to step up
and save the day a woman was being
abducted at gunpoint when seven-year-old
cameron spotted the struggle he saw the
weapon in the man's hand the fear in the
woman's eyes as she looked for a way out
and he knew that he had to act he
concentrated with all his might reaching
out with his mind and threw the gun out
of the man's grasp and into some nearby
bushes the woman ran as fast as she
could from there but not before catching
a glimpse of the child that had saved
her life somehow she knew that he had
been her hero unfortunately for cameron
but fortunately for the scp foundation
the woman reported what had happened to
a nearby police officer who just so
happened to be an undercover agent for
the foundation before cameron could
leave the scene he was being approached
by a team of armed guards and brought to
a strange new place filled with men in
lab coats who kept calling him scp-2241
cameron sat for a very long time in a
white room wondering whether he was in
trouble when a new man in a lab coat
entered he introduced himself as
researcher valdez and told cameron he
was going to ask him some questions he
asked why cameron had helped the woman
instead of running away and getting an
adult to help he said superheroes have
to help people i can move things without
touching them and other people can't so
i should have used that to help them he
went on to explain that he had practiced
his ability in the woods and kept it a
secret from everyone valdes asked what
sort of things cameron could do and he
explained i can move stuff without
touching it but not if it's too far away
or if it's too big only like a cup
across the room or a person's arm or
something sometimes i it can sort of
change as well when prompted he
elaborated sometimes when i'm moving
something it changes to something i want
like one time when i was moving a stone
it changed to look like a toy i lost but
it changed back after a while before i
even got home cameron became distressed
during the interview but valdes promised
him that he would be okay here he asked
cameron what his superhero name would be
and he told him cameron the crusader
valdes explained that cameron would be
staying at the scp foundation for a
while so they could learn more about his
powers and help him become a better
superhero researcher valdes concluded
his interview with this closing
statement
scp-2241 appears to trust me and
believes that the foundation is
attempting to help him as much as
possible
scp-2241's account is consistent with
the early stages of humanoid developing
a reality bending ability
scp-2241 may have experienced abuse at
the hands of its parents leading to
early development of sedability in the
event that a more developed ability is
required for research similar emotional
stress can be applied by foundation
staff
scp-2241 is kept in a standard humanoid
containment chamber he is given access
to television and comic books though
this access can be cut off as punishment
for bad behavior he has fed three
balanced meals a day with additional
treats such as chocolate or ice cream
provided after testing especially if the
testing goes on for a particularly long
time or is exceptionally stressful all
personnel that interact with
scp-2241 are to call him by his name
cameron when interacting with him only
cameron's assigned psychologists and
specifically designated personnel such
as valdez are allowed to develop a
friendly relationship with him if he
becomes attached to an unapproved person
they are required to discourage this
however they can after containment
procedures were established valdez and
his team set to work putting together
tests that would use cameron's emotions
and desires to save people in order to
develop and strengthen his abilities for
the first test they deliberately exposed
cameron to a d-class that believed him
to be a valuable hostage one that he
could use to escape from the foundation
the d-class abducted cameron at
knifepoint but cameron quickly used his
reality bending ability to turn the
knife into chocolate and escape the
knife remained chocolate and did not
turn back to metal indicating his powers
had grown stronger details of events
that followed this test have been
redacted from the official file but a
note from a member of the overwatch
council provides a peek into what might
have happened
scp-2241 has stated that it intends to
grow stronger to stop more people from
dying and this will help both it and us
in this aim killing a man with a
teleported bullet was a stroke of
tactical genius from the scp object mtf
theta 17 will be ready to respond during
all further rounds of testing as a
precaution following a series of tests
each of which included heightened
emotional stakes such as threatening the
lives of innocent bystanders or
treasured items belonging to scp-2241
his abilities developed even further in
one test a series of armed drones were
made to artificially malfunction posing
an apparent threat to foundation
personnel around the boy he responded by
using his telekinesis to turn the drones
on each other crashing them into one
another while only one drone remained he
teleported its weaponry to a nearby
field leaving a harmless shell behind in
another test a bomb was detonated near a
member of d-class personnel the boy
somehow absorbed the energy of the bomb
as it exploded transforming its kinetic
energy and saving the man's life another
bomb-related test featured man with a
bomb strapped to him attacking a d-class
in this test it was ordered that the
bomber be taken alive cameron responded
by teleporting the bomb vest into an
explosion-proof containment chamber and
knocking the bomber unconscious with a
single punch though his tiny fist should
not have been capable of delivering such
a strong blow in another test a third
bomb was placed in
scp-2241's chamber among his personal
belongings including some stuffed
animals and comic books he was very
upset at this discovery and teleported
the bomb high up into the sky where it
detonated harmlessly he remained upset
for a while after repeating no one can
take my things it's not fair i'm strong
i'm the crusader moving on from bombs
the research team tasked the boy with
stealing a box from a foundation bank
vault which had been modified for extra
security he teleported himself into the
vault picked up the box and then made a
mistake he tripped the sensors inside
however he somehow slowed the sensors
down and was able to teleport himself
back out of the vault before the alarm
could sound this was the first task
given to cameron that could be perceived
as morally gray or even villainous but
he performed it without question and
this was recorded as a notable
development next a surprise long-range
attack was performed on the foundation
side by a foundation-owned robotic
mortar 2241 became angry catching the
bomb and throwing it toward the launcher
at a speed that appeared to be
approximately 1.4 times the speed of
sound it was noted that his abilities
were less focused and his demeanor more
violent when he was angry he turned to
an observing researcher and said i hate
them i'm a foundation avenger and i hate
the bad guys and i'm gonna fight them
all for the final test in this series
two d-classes who were described to 2241
as civilians were held at gunpoint in
rooms with bulletproof glass windows he
was told that the guns could not be
affected by his powers the hostages
needed physical contact to be teleported
to safety and he needed to rescue them
both before they were killed shocking
the research team he split into two
versions of himself each teleporting a
hostage to safety before returning to
the crime scene to subdue the bad guys
he reported feeling a bit sick
afterwards but had no other adverse
effects from splitting himself into two
people by the time this series of tests
were completed he was able to teleport
objects as well as his own body
duplicate himself see a few seconds into
the future
and move or transform objects within a
distance of 12 meters he was excited
about these improvements referring to
them as leveling up following these
tests valdez planned to pause the
psychiatric treatment of scp-2241
in favor of a more hands-on approach the
plan was to begin neurological testing
using a surgically implanted chip that
would monitor the boy's brain activity
during combat the ethics committee
caught wind of this and immediately
intervened they temporarily revoked
valdez's security clearance and placed
him under investigation they submitted
an official report on this decision
which read implanting a monitoring chip
into a child this young cannot be done
without significant developmental damage
in later years this will cause
catastrophic problems for both the child
and long-term containment given his
well-developed capabilities additionally
deploying a child in combat even under
testing conditions violates all moral
norms personnel involved in sweeping the
previous rapid fire tests under the rug
are under review the testing and
research surrounding
scp-2241 did not only draw the attention
of the ethics committee but it also
caused discord within the overwatch
council itself following the ethics
committee intervention 05-3 ordered that
testing be resumed writing these tests
are more important than one scp
regardless of as it looks like ankinder
long-term containment and observation is
no longer a priority given the utility
of data we have collected via intensive
testing in the short term the risk of
the scp breaching containment is minimal
given its loyalty we now know which
parts of the brain deal with certain
anomalous abilities with more detail we
can see how we may even learn how to
induce these abilities and we will
definitely learn how to neutralize them
two other members of the council were
horrified by this statement believing
that it went against decency and
morality in a way that could not be
justified o5-4 submitted a statement
this is too far we cannot let this stand
as precedent this is but one step
removed from child soldiers and even
less removed from militarizing an
scp-level object an emergency council
meeting was called to address this
internal disagreement and the majority
voted in favor of reinstating testing
and exonerating valdez of all ethics
violations i believe the results will
justify both the risks and the means
we're closer than ever to understanding
the mechanism by which human brains
interact with extra-normal phenomena the
emotional and eventual neurological
damage to scp-2241
is unfortunate but it is also necessary
for the advancement of our understanding
in addition due to the new modification
of the monitoring hardware 2241 can be
neutralized quickly should it become a
threat at any time after the surgery and
so the protests of the ethics committee
were ignored the concerned members of
the overwatch council overruled and
valdez was allowed to resume his plan
for testing and preparing to craft a
super-powered child into a weapon and
all the while a little boy named cameron
remained the test subject of the scp
foundation still dreaming of the day
when he might have a chance to save the
world
now go check out scp-953 polymorphic
humanoid and scp-213 anti-matter
parasite for more superpowered humanoid
anomalies